Tesla may have six factories around the world.
But none is more important than its
mega factory near Austin, Texas.
This building is the most advanced car
factory that earth has ever seen
If you could put the building on its side,
Tesla’s new headquarters would be taller
than the world’s tallest skyscrapers,
including Dubai’s Burj Khalifa.
According to our calculations, you can fit
194 billion hamsters in this building!
Billions of hamsters and one day millions of
cars are expected to roll off the assembly line.
For the past twenty years, Tesla has been
following its carefully concocted plan
to ‘electrify’ the world.
In 2006, Elon musk released
Tesla’s Master Plan Part 1, on its website.
It consisted of, first, “building a sports
car” - the Roadster. It was really expensive,
with a starting price of over $100,000,
Second, “Using that money to build an affordable
car” - the Model S and X - though both are pricey
and still out of the reach of most.
Third: “Use that money to build an
even more affordable car” - which gave us
the Model 3 and the Model Y crossover.
Finally, “While doing above, also provide
zero-emission electric power generation options”.
In reference to Tesla’s solar
lineup of solar panels, roof tiles,
and powerwalls to supply energy to your home.
A decade later, Tesla came out with
Master Plan, part Deux, or Part Two.
“Create stunning solar roofs with
seamlessly integrated battery storage.”
Tesla’s solar tiles have been more difficult
to install than originally thought because
no two roofs are the same. I went into detail in
another video that I’ll link in my description.
Second, “Expand the electric vehicle
product line to address all major segments”
Besides the S, 3, X, and Y, Tesla’s Cybertruck
is FINALLY slated to go into production next
year according to Musk after a longggg
wait. The semi is also in progress.
Third, “Develop a self-driving
capability that is 10X safer than
manual via massive fleet learning”.
The software to make the Tesla fully
self-driving is still being developed.
Which is connected to the final point of
Master Plan part 2: “Enable your car to make
money for you when you aren't using it.”
A self-driving network of cars, or robotaxis,
is dependent on FSD being complete.
In March, Musk confirmed he’s
working on Master Plan Part
3…despite Part Two not being fully finished.
However, he’s always been one to look ahead.
Part three is likely to see electric
cars streaming off assembly lines
at a rate never before seen.
A scale that no company has ever
achieved in the history of humanity.
Tesla’s growth has already been astounding. It’s
the fastest-growing car manufacturer in the world,
currently delivering a million cars a year.
But if you know anything about Elon
Musk - his appetite is bigger.
If Tesla’s share of the total vehicle
output market globally is about 1%...Musk
says his company is aiming for 20% of the pie.
In other words, he wants 1 out of every five
new cars on the road to be one of his.
Musk has repeatedly said developing prototypes
are a piece of cake compared to the complicated
process of scaling up production.
The only way to achieve that scale is to make
your factory as efficient as possible.
The layout of Giga Texas is very
different compared to Tesla’s original
headquarters in Fremont, California.
Fremont’s factory consisted of separate
buildings making different parts. For example,
the seats were made in a totally different
building from the main assembly line.
So it wasn’t as efficient as it could have been.
Whereas now, with Giga Texas, everything is under
one roof. Almost like an integrated circuit.
Raw materials come in one door, and the
finished product goes out the other.
Within the factory, Tesla is also
simplifying the way it makes its cars
thanks to its giant casting machines known as
the Giga Press. The Austin-made Model Ys are
produced with only two body pieces at the front
and rear whereas the Model 3s have 171 pieces.
The Ys also contain 1,600 fewer welds. Fewer steps
on the production line translate to lower cost.
Speaking of lowering costs, Tesla is building
its own battery cells in house, the 4680s.
These next generation batteries pack more energy,
the company says they’ll have 16% more range.
They’re totally different from
the batteries of the past.
In the same way that aircraft wings store
fuel instead of needing a fuel tank,
Tesla decided to build a battery pack
that doesn’t contain excess structure.
So, what’s next for Tesla?
It could truly transform into an AI company.
Musk has always insisted the goal of Tesla
is not to be a car company but a technology
company that’s developing software so the
cars can drive themselves.
Although we thought robotaxis
were going to look like regular Teslas,
Musk has alluded to a “futuristic look”.
He said on Tesla’s first quarter of
earnings call that the robotaxi won’t
have a steering wheel or pedals, and the
company is targeting 2024 for production.
If the Cybertruck is anything to go by, then
the robotaxi will likely turn heads as well.
All of the tech in the Teslas is expected
to be packed into their robots.
According to Tesla, the Optimus comes
complete with autopilot cameras in the
head and a full self-driving computer in the body.
The bot is designed to take care of boring,
repetitive tasks that humans normally do,
like running to the grocery store.
When Musk revealed the Tesla bot at
the company’s AI day in 2021,
some thought it was a joke.
It didn’t help that the bot was actually
a human dressed as a robot since there’s
not yet a prototype.
But according to Musk,
this is no laughing matter.
Clip I was surprised that people did not realize
the magnitude of the Optimus robot program.
Those who are insightful or listen carefully will
understand that Optimus ultimately will be worth
more than the car business. Worth more than FSD.
The labor market is reported to be
16 times greater than the car market.
If Tesla produces a robot that can do what we do,
this could reshape what we do with
our time beyond our imagination.
Tesla started out twenty years ago as a
company trying to build an electric car.
Now it’s trying to develop cars that
will one day drive themselves.
And if it accomplishes that, it will transform
into an AI company with an army of robotaxis and
robots, and a full clean energy suite that
is all tied together in one neat package.
Here at Newsthink, I’m involved in every
aspect of the storytelling process:
from research to scriptwriting to video editing.
I try to be as productive as possible
and it really helps to be healthy.
Ever since I began taking
BiOptimizers at the start of the year,
I’ve found that I’ve functioned much better.
My doctor suggested I take probiotics to improve
digestive health. So that’s what I’ve been doing,
I’ve been taking their probiotics with
my lunch every day. And for dinner,
I take magnesium breakthrough which I’ve found
has significantly helped improve my sleep.
Ever since I started taking magnesium breakthrough
I can actually sleep through the
entire night without waking up.
Most magnesium supplements fail because
they’re synthetic or use preservatives.
When you get all seven
critical forms of magnesium,
your body gets a serious upgrade so you
can feel better throughout your day.
To find out more, head
magnesiumbreakthrough.com/newsthink
to get a 10% discount. My custom link
is in my description and pinned comment.
And don’t forget to use my promo
code: NEWSTHINK10 at checkout.
Thanks for watching. For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom